what up space fam golson here from anime
up pro back at it again to discuss
one piece the response on my every yonko
in their powers explain video was great
so i decided it was about time to do a
video
based on every yonkos backstory i think
we're all interested in how these mad
lads came to be
if you do enjoy seeing one piece videos
like this one on the channel and want to
keep them coming the best thing you can
do is smash that like button and share
this video with any cultured pirates
that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos and as you wait for the next one
to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i got videos about
the yonko and their powers
warlords supernovas and much more before
we continue a quick thank you to
this plate for sponsoring this video
i've actually owned several disc plates
for years
even before it was cool and i've always
loved their product a disc plate is a
one of a kind metal poster that you can
customize
collect and use to sharply increase the
cool factor
of any space whether it's your room your
office or even the bathroom the quality
and durability of these posters is
incredible and i can say from experience
that even after several years
a display looks as good as on the first
day on top of that it only takes like 20
seconds or less to set them up with this
plate's easy to use mounting system
no power tools no damages no
frustrations
and this plate is more than just a
poster company
they support emerging artists through
their licensed art marketplace and they
believe in helping people
and helping the planet they are part of
the massive forest garden project which
has planted over 12 million trees in
africa
and for every print you purchase they
will plant one new baby tree
check them out for yourself just click
that top link in the description
and if you act now you can take
advantage of their big halloween sale
get 30 off when you buy one or two disc
plates
and 36 off when you buy three or more
click the link and see the quality for
yourself
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
at this point i probably don't need to
explain that the yonko aka emperors are
a big deal
we're talking influence huge bounties
the strongest pirate cruise one of the
great powers that balance the world and
so on
if you want an even more detailed
breakdown on what it means to be a yonko
then i recommend you check out my
original every yonko in their powers
explained video that i'll link in the
description but for this one let's just
jump into specific yonko
and i'm going to begin with the man
known as the strongest man
in the world the late great edward
newgate aka whitebeard although he
passed away
whitebeard was as legendary as you can
hope to get
he was part of the strongest crew during
the rox era
then he was a rival to gold d roger the
pirate king
and then he became a yonko with the
highest bounty a bounty over
5 billion berries he was even called the
man closest to the one piece
so let's rewind time and see how this
legendary figure known as whitebeard
came to be
whitebeard was born on the island of
sphinx it was too poor to pay the
heavenly tribute and thus two poor to
remain part of the world government as a
result it became a lawless island that
suffered from pirates and slavers
running amok
the poor country collapsed and created a
fresh generation of orphans
whitebeard was one of these orphans he
went to see at a young age while he
continued to pump
pirate money and supplies into his
village all throughout his life
although he didn't have a family there
that village would always be his home
so yeah whitebeard didn't have it easy
he had to grow up in poverty with no
parents
meaning he had to grow up all the
quicker in his early days of being a
pirate when he was just another member
of a crew
and going by his real name newgate he
was called out for not being interested
in treasure
his fellow crew member asked him what he
wanted
and the young newgate said he still
wanted the same thing he wanted ever
since he was a boy
a family clearly growing up as an orphan
significantly shaped whitebeard and his
goals because he didn't have a family
growing up
he never took such things for granted
and would eventually go on to form a
crew
that would serve as his family where the
crew members were viewed as his sons
but before that happened he joined the
rock's pirates one of the most legendary
and op pirate crews in the history of
one piece the rock's pirates were led
by captain rox d zebek and it not only
included a younger whitebeard but a
younger big mom
and a younger kaido as well the list of
op crew members goes on but the point is
they were hella strong and they ruled
the seas before the rise of gold d
roger the story goes that during the god
valley incident the rox pirates the
strongest crew in the world were wiped
out on an island called
god valley according to sengoku in order
to protect the celestial dragons and
their slaves
at god valley garp joined forces with
gold d roger and they broke apart the
infamous
rox pirates then whitebeard founded his
own pirate crew the whitebeard pirates
at some point they got shipwrecked on
wano and met kozuki odin the two briefly
clashed and odin caused whitebeard to
break a sweat before odin
asked to ride on whitebeard's ship
whitebeard wasn't a fan of the idea
initially
he could tell that odin was not the type
of person to serve someone else he was a
leader and whitebeard knew what happens
when you got people like that together
in a group
he said he had plenty of bad experiences
with that in his last crew this suggests
that this was one of the big issues with
the rox pirates it wasn't necessarily
that they weren't strong enough to
survive
but rather that they had too many
leaders in one group so that they
couldn't function effectively the
whitebeard liked odin but he nonetheless
tried to leave before odin would notice
but odin yearned for adventure so bad
that he prepared for this
he attached a chain to their ship and
wouldn't let go or accept no as an
answer
eventually whitebeard gave in to odin's
stubbornness he let him aboard his ship
but notably referred to him as little
brother rather than
son eazol was there at this point too
since he had held on to odin
when the latter held onto the chain and
ezo was pulled aboard
and also inuarashi and nekomamushi were
stowed away in the ship
so all of them joined whitebeard's crew
for this period two years after odin
joined whitebeard created divisions and
made odin the commander of the second
division
at some point whitebeard met marshall d
teach
aka blackbeard and let him join the crew
four years after odin joined the crew
hiyori and momonosuke were already born
and the whitebeard pirates encountered
gold d roger and his crew
at this super hype moment we saw odin
attack roger and then get sent
flying then whitebeard proceeded to
attack roger each person's hockey was so
strong
that when they clashed their weapons
weren't even touching
the two crews then proceeded to battle
for three days and three nights
neither got the upper hand and the
attempt to pillage one another became a
gift exchange
it was at this point that young shanks
and buggy got to beat blackbeard
and buggy mentioned that they say that
blackbeard never slept in his life and
called him a monster but more on
blackbeard later at this point roger had
yet to reach the final island
and he needed odin's help since odin
could read the poneglyphs
at this point goldie roger bowed his
head to whitebeard while asking to
borrow odin for a year
roger's crew was outraged but that's
another thing you can say about
whitebeard the pirate king himself
bowed to him whitebeard was outraged at
first viewing the request as roger tried
to steal his family from him
as we know by now if there is one thing
that whitebeard values above all
else it's his crew a gays family
whitebeard was not happy at all but
eventually let odin leave because he
wanted to
roger left him a fortune in exchange for
letting him borrow odin but it did
little to ease the upset whitebeard
and he even told his crew to give them
back the food so that odin's family
doesn't go hungry
even after they part ways whitebeard
can't help but care deeply
about odin and his family ezo stayed
with blackbeard while inuarashi
nekomamushi joined odin and his family
once when shanks met with whitebeard
whitebeard told him that his crew
clashed with roger so many times
that he began to remember faces among
his crew including shanks's face and
buggy's face
and that right there adds to the legend
of buggy d clown but anyways
roger proceeded to make it to the last
island called laugh tale
which should hold the one piece he
became the pirate king but there
remained a respect between whitebeard
and roger their relationship remained
one of equals
shortly before roger's death the two met
up to say their goodbyes
keep in mind roger was terminally ill
before the famous execution they drained
together and roger even offered to tell
whitebeard how to get the laugh tale
but whitebeard refused the offer saying
he wouldn't go even if roger told him
where it was because he wasn't
interested
whitebeard could have got there and even
claimed the one piece
but he was never interested in that
ironically the man closest to one piece
had no desire to get it
roger proceeded to tell whitebeard about
the significance
about people with d in their name at one
point after the famous pirate shiki the
golden lion escaped from impel
down he came to whitebeard he proclaimed
that it was now whitebeard's era
with roger gone shiki spoke of a plan
but the main thing i enjoyed seeing was
how little respect
whitebeard paid to someone as legendary
as shiki he straight up said that if
shiki came to babble nonsense at him
then he'll toss him overboard not many
people could talk like that to the
golden lion
after the golden lion went to seclusion
whitebeard became the undisputed top dog
since he was the only one who could
fight on equal terms with the pirate
king before he got executed
when shanks went to visit whitebeard we
also learned that whitebeard witnessed
shanks's duel with mihawk
and that it is still fresh in his memory
so he definitely stayed in the loop of
pirate happenings
eventually the world government gave
whitebeard the title of one of the four
emperors of the sea
because of his immense power and based
on his bounty
it appears that they continued to view
him as the most dangerous despite his
growing age and failing hell
and then whitebeard did another thing to
cement how good of a guy he is
he went on to help fishman island and
all of the fishermen and merfolk living
there
as jinbei explained all pirates who
sailed the grand line eventually have to
pass
fishman island when the great age of
pirates began the island was ravaged
it had been overwhelmed by pirates and
naval forces chasing after them
many fishermen and merfolk were captured
and sold off
it was terrible and according to jimbei
everyone was in despair but whitebeard
came to rescue he proclaimed that it was
his territory and thus put it under his
protection
one of the reasons he did this was also
because he was good friends with king
neptune but anyways
when he proclaimed the territory as his
own with that one sentence he ended the
plundering of fishman island
jinbei says that that's power and he
also notes that whitebeard protected
many other islands like that as well
before he met ace swiper read about him
in the papers and thought he had a lot
of spirit for an upstart
since he turned down an offer to be one
of the seven warlords of the sea
then one day ace was looking for
whitebeard but ended up fighting
jinbei for five days straight because
jinbei didn't want to let ace get to
whitebeard
it's kind of funny after the two
collapse on the ground from exhaustion
from this
long fight whitebeard shows up and says
and i quote
so you want to take my head then have at
it
i'll take you on imagine being in a
five-day battle
without getting the upper hand and then
the strongest yonko showing up to battle
you
not exactly ideal conditions for victory
ace then told his men to run
before being completely overpowered by
whitebeard still though
whitebeard was so impressed that ace
continued to get up that he decided it
would be a waste to kill him
he told him that if he wants to
terrorize the seas to do it in his name
then whitebeard offered his hand and
told ace to become his son
now ace being ace wasn't one to start
blindly following someone just like that
he tried to assassinate whitebeard
multiple times but he always failed
whitebeard was so confident that he let
ace roam around with no chains
even after over a hundred assassination
attempts and even though he was already
old and had tubes sticking out from his
nose his crew would even save
ace when he was thrown overboard during
a failed attempt
eventually ace stopped trying to kill
whitebeard and whitebeard wanted ace to
be the division
2 commander but ace doubted himself he
told whitebeard that he was roger's son
aka the son of whitebeard's enemy
thinking that whitebeard would want him
to get lost but whitebeard didn't even
think that that was important enough to
discuss
he said we're all children of the sea so
it doesn't matter where anyone's from or
who their father
is ace was shocked and he'd go on to
become one of whitebeard's most loyal
men
however when blackbeard who was in aces
division killed 4th division commander
thatch
ace decided to go after him on his own
against the wishes of whitebeard who had
a bad feeling about this one
ace didn't listen but it was because
he'd come to respect whitebeard so much
for him blackbeard threw dirt in
whitebeard's face
and ran and ace refused to let anyone
dishonor whitebeard's name
that is the kind of love and passion
that whitebeard inspired his sons
even ones that wanted to kill him at
first and the story of the epic
whitebeard goes on but that's it for the
backstory
portion where we got a sense of the kind
of man whitebeard was
selfless caring and strong af too if you
do want me to cover his whole life at
some point or one of the other yonko's
lives
let me know in the comments it's an epic
life definitely
worthy of its own video but for now
let's move on to shanks's backstory
shanks is relatively young for a yonko
only 39 years old after the time skip
and yet has already accomplished so much
and has one of the most hyped auras
around him
let's look at the origins of this
mysterious and epic dude
shanks is from the west blue and as we
saw around 30 years ago
at the age of 9 or so he was an
apprentice on gold d rogers crew
luffy in contrast is 17 when he sets out
on his pirate adventure
so shanks got into the game young along
with his clown friend buggy
he's seen reading the paper with buggy
and they're both ticked off because the
news is about whitebeard rather than
about the roger pirates
at this point shanks already has the
straw hat that used to belong to roger
it's the same iconic hat that he'd go on
to get to luffy one day
buggy and shanks would argue hard about
whether it's colder in the north pole
or the south pole and they'd both get
really into it just like brothers
silver's rayleigh would get annoyed by
them hit them
and lecture them about how it didn't
matter where it was colder
but if they really wanted to know they
should go find out for themselves rather
than pointlessly argue
which is great advice less talk and more
action is definitely a winning mindset
buggy was like a male clown nami in the
sense i love the idea of treasure and
becoming rich
for shanks though it clearly wasn't
about the treasure and as a result buggy
said that shanks and the others aboard
the crew
were soft because they didn't have the
proper appreciation for booty
buggy tells shanks that he's lost sight
of what being a pirate is about and for
him it's clearly about getting treasure
and wealth
however that's one of the interesting
things about one piece everyone makes up
their own definition of what it means to
be a pirate
and for people like luffy it means
freedom and i gotta say
i prefer that answer even as a young
person shank seems to have liked booze
but even then as a youngster shanks knew
he'd go off on his own someday
as the captain of his own ship he mainly
focused his attention on making time to
see the world while mentioning that he'd
do some pirating too
so it seems like exploration adventure
and discovering what the world has to
offer through travel
were definitely some of shanks's main
motivating factors he definitely never
wanted to work for buggy explaining that
they think differently
so they'd be better off going their own
separate ways being a pirate is all
about going your own way
shank said again emphasizing the
importance of freedom
that luffy values too buggy said that if
they ever crossed paths on the high
seas it would be a fight to the finish
and shanks agreed
saying that's also what being a pirate
is about so despite being called soft by
buggy
shanks always knew that fighting and
even killing were parts of being a
pirate
after shanks tells buggy one day that
the crew has discovered a devil fruit
buggy doesn't care
until he hears it's worth a lot of money
he pretends to eat it but eats a fake
and steals the real thing one day though
shanks catches him by surprise
buggy puts the fruit in his mouth shanks
leaves thinking that buggy is stealing
food
only to suddenly come back surprising
buggy into swallowing the devil fruit he
never wanted to swallow
because he thought losing power to swim
would be ridiculous for a pirate
buggy then jumps overboard for a
treasure map and can't swim because he
ate the fruit and all
despite the arguments they had shanks
didn't hesitate to jump in and save
buggy
he also wore a concerned expression on
his face when he jumped overboard
the most hilarious thing is that buggy
framed this story
as shanks making him swallow a hundred
million berries
while luffy saw the story for what it
was a story of how shanks
saved buggy's life the roger pirates
eventually clashed with the golden lion
pirates led by shiki
in what became known as the ed war shiki
wanted goldie roger to become his
right-hand man
so they could conquer the world but
roger obviously wouldn't do something
like that
and so they fought according to roger he
didn't want to rule anything he asked
what's the point of being a pirate
if you don't do things the way you want
but before the battle
buggy was freaking out about the golden
lion and worried about his life
while shanks was super calm saying who
cares buggy won't die if he gets cut
into pieces anymore
because of his devil fruit powers i love
this that kid shanks could even be calm
when his life was in danger as mentioned
during whitebeard's backstory
the two crews meeting the whitebeard and
roger pirates
met on an island and clashed before
chilling out and finishing on pretty
good terms with one another
four days after the initial clash was
when buggy noticed blackbeard
and how he didn't sleep a wink during
the ceasefire last night
or the night before and how they say
that he never slept in his life
the way that buggy and shanks respond to
the same piece of info
tells us a lot about their characters
even though they're so young here
it was remarked that both shanks and
buggy already had the attitude of grown
men
but they were very different for shanks
blackbeard is lucky
and his life must be twice as fun
because he doesn't need to sleep but
buggy insists on focusing on the fact
that he's a monster
buggy is more freaked out while shanks
is more excited and impressed
thus with such contrasting personalities
it makes sense that the two were
constantly arguing but that doesn't
change the fact that they were super
close and always seen together
to the point that even whitebeard
remember them together after this
encounter with the whitebeard pirates
as we saw during whitebeard's backstory
odin ended up joining the roger pirates
and together they went on to visit skype
as well
they went on to many places like water 7
and fishman island
toki fell ill and had to disembark in
wano and inuarashi nekomamushi
disembarked with her while she made odin
carry on in the adventure
soon after buggy caught a fever and had
to forego the voyage to laugh tale
and shanks being the mad lad he is
decided to stay
and care for buggy saying if we're gonna
go to the final island
we'll take our own ship someday odin
said that he didn't know
if shanks and bungie were best friends
or mortal enemies which i feel like
captures their relationship perfectly
but wow you really got a good sense of
how good of a guy shanks is
through his backstory as well with a
smile on his face
he missed out on the final leg of the
voyage and rodgers went on to be hailed
for circumnavigating the globe
and conquering the sea becoming the king
of the pirates as a result
afterwards roger did regroup with shanks
and buggy shanks asked roger something
we do not know exactly what it was but
possibly about his terminal illness
and then shanks shed tears afterwards at
some point
buggy offered to lend odin a hand if he
needed
it and shanks offered to help as well if
he needed anything
which is why i think it would be awesome
if he came to wano
and helped carry out odin's wish for it
but we'll see if that pans out
but anyways roger disbanded the crew
after he came back from laughdale
and became the pirate king he got off
the ship first
and told them to make sure to get odin
home next at this point roger was
already in the final stages of his
disease
and his crew and especially shanks and
buggy cried when he left
one year after the crew was disbanded
roger turned himself in to the world
government
shanks was present at the execution and
he cried after roger was executed as did
buggy despite what he said before
shanks asked buggy to come along with
him after the execution at
logtown but buggy was not down to become
one of shanks's subordinates
since then shanks has heard rumors about
buggy's pirating
shanks went on to create his own crew he
went to seer village to recruit yasuo
usop's dad after hearing of his
reputation
at some point he also got the three
scars he has
on his left eye from blackbeard who was
still a member of whitebeard's crew
shanks would later tell whitebeard that
it's the only scar he has that still
aches and that he didn't get the scar
because he was careless implying that
blackbeard was a beast
even before his acquisition of two op
devil fruits
shanks was also known to duel with
mihawk the greatest swordsman in the
world
in fact whitebeard mentions that
shanks's duel with mihawk
is still fresh in his memory when they
meet clearly it was an epic duel and
although this
isn't technically backstory whitebeard
mentioned that everyone was surprised
beyond belief
when shanks came back with a missing arm
from the east blue
not believing that any opponent could do
that to him the rest is pretty
straightforward
12 years ago shanks arrived at dawn
island and met
luffy shanks made the village his
temporary base for a year luffy got
attached and wished to join the crew
but shanks wouldn't let him because he
was too young then we can cue
shanks giving the straw hat to luffy and
giving up his arm for him
again shanks's whole life would be worth
looking at but since this is about
backstories we should be moving on but
from what we've seen thus far whitebeard
and shanks were definitely more on the
side of good than bad
when you look at their characters let's
see if that keeps up as we look at
blackbeard aka marshall d
teach the first yonko will be looking at
with the infamous
d in his name around the time that odin
was put in charge of the second division
of the whitebeard pirates they
encountered teach
teach was an orphan who begged to join
the whitebeard pirates
saying he had nowhere else to go he even
had a tear in his
eye whitebeard decided to let the 12
year old future yonko join his crew
which is not really surprising because
after hearing his backstory
we know how much whitebeard values
family and how much he'd take pity on an
orphan
who didn't have any blackbeard is one of
the most interesting characters in one
piece for me
because of his level of planning and
patience you then add his ever growing
power
and you got one of my favorite anime
antagonists ever according to blackbeard
all his life
he was searching for the yami yami no me
aka the dark dark fruit that turns you
into a darkness human
this is the reason he stayed on
whitebeard's ship for decades
because he knew it was his best chance
of finding that specific fruit
in blackbeard's view him having this
specific devil fruit
that's said to be the most dangerous in
the history of all devil fruit powers
makes him the strongest in the world but
i'm getting ahead of myself
yes blackbeard was apparently always
looking for the dark dark fruit
but many things happened before he
eventually killed fourth division
commander of the white beard pirates
thatch
and took it for himself and by the way
the historical blackbeard's name was
edward teach
and alternatively spelled edward thatch
so it's interesting that one piece
blackbeard marshall d
teach killed the other person thatch who
was also a reference to the historic
blackbeard's name
it's like he wanted to make it clear
that there could only be one blackbeard
but real history aside we mentioned the
clash between the whitebeard
pirates and roger pirates where they
fought they partied and eventually odin
went with roger
this is the third and last time we'll be
quickly bringing this up because the
other yonko that will come next weren't
present
shanks is supposed to be only a bit
younger than blackbeard so it's cool
that the two youngest yonko met each
other so early on
when they were working under the two
strongest pirates blackbeard was curious
about shanks and buggy and
asked if they were apprentices as
mentioned the two apprentices didn't
look very tough
but they had the attitudes of grown men
then we jump to the perspective of
shanks and buggy and at this point
bungie mentions that blackbeard didn't
sleep a wink during the ceasefire last
night or the night before and that they
say blackbeard never slept in his life
even though he was just a kid buggy
viewed him as a monster and there's some
truth to that
the fact that they clashed for three
days and nights and no one saw a
blackbeard sleep
not even after the fighting was over
it's pretty crazy and it builds up the
terrifying mystery
around blackbeard as well when sheiki
went to visit whitebeard
after the prison break and around 18
year old blackbeard is seen on board
looking much more similar to his
present-day self and it's perfect that
he's just
chilling in the background and you can
easily miss him if you don't pay
attention it is exactly what is so
terrifying about blackbeard
that he could keep his true motives and
intentions a secret for so long
at some point later blackbeard and
shanks would clash again
and this time blackbeard would leave the
three scars over shanks's eye
and as shanks made clear it was not
because he was careless
shanks straight up tells us that even
before he got his op devil through
powers
blackbeard was seemingly good enough to
get the better of a prepared shanks in a
battle and he left a deep impression on
shanks mentally
not just physically and to me this is
one of the craziest details we have
about blackbeard
sure we don't see how it happened and we
don't know how much weaker
shanks was than compared to now but
shanks a yonko
clearly feels like blackbeard is a very
dangerous being
i mentioned how whitebeard promoted ace
to second division commander and ace had
a convo with blackbeard about it
as ace told blackbeard i quote you've
been with whitebeard the longest and
quote
everyone knew blackbeard clearly had the
strength to step up and ace was saying
he'd be the better choice too because
he'd been on the crew for decades
this is just a brief moment in an ace
focused flashback but wow it's so good
blackbeard looks so content and merry as
he stuffs his face with food
he laughs and replies that he doesn't
have those kinds of ambitions
and encourages ace to be the commander
meanwhile he was plotting to become the
strongest
and the next pirate king the whole time
blackbeard's ambition was arguably the
highest
it could get and yet he played the role
of unambitious
supportive crewmate perfectly so that no
one expected him for decades let's just
say if he ever played as the imposter in
among us
he would never be sus i think shanks
said it best
when he said that blackbeard laid low
and waited for his chance
he didn't even rise up to become a squad
leader or make a name for himself
he hid himself behind a giant shadow of
whitebeard
and once he had enough power he finally
made his move
as shanks says a man like that will
never be satisfied he'll keep aiming for
the top
end quote and that's what makes
blackbeard so terrifying
his ability to plan and wait his
patience
but anyways blackbeard proceeded to kill
thatch
take the yamaminomi and start his own
crew
it was then that he adopted the name
blackbeard and formed the blackbeard
pirates and blackbeard is sort of the
perfect name
because he's kind of implying that
whitebeard's era is over
with his very name since a whitebeard
suggests old age
while a blackbeard in contrast suggests
vitality or a man in his prime
ace went chasing after blackbeard
because blackbeard was in his division
killed a brother and disgraced
whitebeard even though shanks and
whitebeard did not want ace to go
since they both had a bad feeling about
blackbeard interestingly enough before
luffy arrived to drum kingdom
blackbeard and his crew pillaged it and
sent wahpool fleeing in the process
and as a result actually liberated the
drum kingdom
from him as ironic as that sounds and
again plenty more interesting things
happened
involving the now two devil fruit having
master planning yonko blackbeard but
since this is about backstories
it's about time to move on to kaido the
pirate dubbed the strongest creature in
the world
so over 40 years ago a young kaido was
an apprentice on the famous rock's
pirates crew
his crew members included fellow future
yonko whitebeard and fellow futureyonko
big mom
and i'm focusing on the yonko in
particular but many other powerful
pirates were members of the rock's
pirates
including the golden lion the silver axe
captain john
wang ji captain rox himself and so on
at some point big mom did something that
made kaido owe her big time
although kaido would later say that's in
the past big mom responded that it is a
lifelong debt
so we have yet to figure out what
exactly big mom did to put kaido in her
debt but it's definitely something that
will be revealed down the line
38 years ago at god valley the rox
pirates the strongest crew in the world
were defeated by the combined forces of
monkey d
garp and goldy roger according to the
news at least
the rox pirates were a rampaging force
of evil that
none had been able to stop up until this
point after this battle the rox pirates
were broken apart but obviously many of
the members survived and continued to
thrive long after
one of them was kaido and although he's
arguably portrayed as the strongest
living yonko he's not undefeatable
we were told that since he became a
pirate he tasted defeat on seven
different occasions
and he's been caught by the navy or
enemy ships no less than 18
times he was tortured time and time
again and
lived as a prisoner he was sentenced to
death 40 times
but when he was hanged the rope snapped
when put under the guillotine the blade
cracked
when skewered the spear broke and he
sank nine different prison vessels
nobody was able to kill him and that
included himself
now that's how kylo was introduced to us
so although he's been portrayed as
unkillable
so far he hasn't been portrayed as
unbeatable
and he was defeated and captured
multiple times throughout his life
so that does bode well for luffy and the
wano arc
we're told 33 years before the present
day the remnants of the legendary rox
pirates including kaido
began to gather new comrades aka crews
and were expanding in claims and infamy
as we know at some point after goldie
rogers execution
kaido along with shanks whitebeard and
big mom was recognized as one of the top
pirates in the world
and became one of the four emperors of
the sea twenty-eight years ago
kaido had a daughter named yamato if she
is in fact his biological daughter as
has been suggested kaido joined forces
with rochi
and supported him as the shogun of wano
25 years ago odin had come back
from his pirate adventures and wanted to
retake control of wano
from the traitorous orochi but fearing
what would happen to the people
he made a deal with orochi and kaido he
would not fight and dance like a fool in
public
once a week odin did this because he
believed that the citizens would be
spared and orochi and kaido would leave
in five years
i don't know why he believed this from
someone like orochi but it appears that
he did believe him
two years after odin returned to wano
kaido had a battle with gekko moria and
the gecko pirates
the result was the loss of moria's crew
moria was left wanting revenge against
kaido
and he still wants it so it would
totally make sense if he popped up in
wano
to help luffy's side just saying
sometime around this point a young
yamato would have told kaido that she
wanted to be
kozuki odin and he would have clobbered
her for saying so
after five years of odin dancing not
only did orochi have no intention of
leaving with kaido
but they moved in to build a number of
new weapons factories in wano they
imprisoned hyogoro
and killed 16 of his men in the process
along with his wife
odin had had enough and decided it was
finally time to strike down kaido
this is when kaido reveals everything
that he sensed that his own side was at
a disadvantage then
they had less numbers and the samurai
and yakuza working together
could have been a difficult battle and
so kaido manipulated odyn and made him
think he was choosing a method that
would not hurt anyone
kaido comments that roger and whitebeard
will like that too mighty but
soft the fight begins and it lasts
longer than expected because as we're
told
odin's strength surpassed the enemy's
imagination
odin cut kaido and gave him the big
x-shaped scar
he has to this day people were shocked
that he landed such a blow
on the so-called invincible kaido it 100
seemed like odin had the upper hand odyn
had shook him and he was charging again
saying never come back to wano but then
he was distracted
it seemed like his son was captured and
in danger and so he stopped and kaido
took advantage of the moment to bring
odin down
it wasn't actually his son though but
kurozumi higurashi
who used the power of the clone clone
fruit to copy his appearance
so kaido won but not exactly fair and
square now let's move on to the boiling
execution
kaido seemed to get everything he wanted
odin asked for a chance for him and his
samurai to survive
he said that all 10 would enter and if
any would stand the boiling oil for the
amount of time
kaido agrees upon then they would be
allowed to go
free it was supposed to be an
instantaneous death sentence
so kaido laughed and agreed to an hour
again you might ask yourself
why would odin believe him when he
already lied before
and he wasn't that trustworthy to begin
with but he agreed to the terms given by
kaido nonetheless
at this point though he arguably had no
choice since the alternative was certain
death for all of them anyways
so i'll sort of brush past the non-kaido
parts here odin gets in the boiling oil
tells his nine samurai to get on a plank
that he's holding and he proceeds to not
only stay alive but to hold them up for
the full hour
some of the viewers probably kaido as
well were disappointed that odin wasn't
dying in agony or screaming out
odin was stoic the entire time shinobu
was the one who revealed the truth
that odin was dancing to protect the
people from kaido and orochi who had no
interest in the well-being of wano and
its people
in fact urochi straight up wanted to
ruin the country
as a means of revenge for the
persecution of his people the truth was
out but it was too late
since they were all surrounded by kaido
and orochi's men but odin made a speech
odin said that kaido orochi would kill
him but he wanted the people of wana to
carry on his will and to open up wano in
his stead
odin the legend as mentioned survives a
full hour to the great applause and
cheer of the people of wano but kaido
was frowning
of course orochi has no integrity and
had no intention of keeping the deal
he changed it to execution by firing
squad but odin threw up the samurai
and told them to open up wano and the
act allowed them all to escape
interestingly enough kaido apologized
for what happened with the old hag
he had the clone clone fruit user killed
clearly he didn't feel right about the
way he won
so there is some kind of moral compass
there some guilt that clearly isn't
there with orochi but it has its limits
since the fair thing would have been to
free odin and fight him one-on-one again
and to keep the agreement to spare him
if he survives for one hour
but he didn't and i think the fact that
odin behaved so honorably even in the
face of defeat and death
while kaido had to resort to such
dishonorable means tore him up over the
years and haunted him that could even be
part of the reason that he drinks so
much and even tries to take his own life
in the hopes of drowning out that sense
of guilt and shame nevertheless
kaido killed odin with his gun yamato
was present during the legendary
hour and would go on to be one of those
who would carry on odin's will which
would have infuriated kaido more than
anything odin represented everything he
wasn't and what he hated in himself and
when his
own child reminded him of odin by saying
that she was odin
he would lose it and clobber her he
would also go on to put explosive
shackles on her hands
to prevent yamato from escaping
onigashima however back to immediately
after the execution
kaido attacked odin castle he had a
chance to kill the young son abode in
momonosuke
however after witnessing him crying and
noticing how young he was
he decided against it instead of sending
him falling to his death he let him go
and left him to possibly perish in the
flames of the castle
it may not seem like a big difference
but doing this
he shows he wasn't willing to kill the
boy directly and he gave him a chance
however small of surviving
and he did survive again there's that
glimpse of kaido's conscience
which doesn't always win out but is
clearly more active than orochi's
kaido also managed to get his hands on
one of the four road poneglyphs that are
needed to find the exact location of
laughtale
and the one piece kaido went on to
brutally put down a rebellion that took
place 10 years ago
he also crossed paths at some point with
truth maru the leader of the mount atama
thieves aka
ashwara doji and has been wanting to
recruit him ever since
then most recently kaido was working
with warlord doflamingo and mad
scientist caesar clown
on smiles aka artificial zone devil
fruits
these fake fruits helped kaido increase
the power of the beast's pirates
when they worked these fake fruits
allowed kaido to give beast pirate
members
animal based powers even when there
weren't any actual zone devil fruits
available
thus you can probably see why smiles are
very useful to have
for the leader of the beast pirates and
the so-called strongest creature in the
world
kaido wants to rule over a big and op
animal kingdom
although it wasn't technically before
the main one-piece story started
it's also worth mentioning that kaido
was going to try to kill whitebeard
before the paramount war but shanks
interfered somehow
we have no idea how shanks changed
kaido's mind but the beastly yonko
didn't show up to maureen ford
so shanks clearly managed to persuade
him and then the red-haired yonko
showed up to marineford unscathed and
proceeded to stop the fighting there too
very intriguing indeed and i hope we
find out more about this encounter
as we move forward and that about covers
kaido's complex backstory
so for the purposes of this video let's
now turn to yonko big mom
aka charlotte lindland who is currently
in an alliance with kaido in the story
her current bounty is 4 billion 388
million berries the second highest of
any living yonko the first being kaidos
so yeah their alliance is most
definitely a big deal and this alliance
arguably happened because of the history
these two share which was in part
revealed through their backstories
but let's start at the beginning when
she was about five but absolutely
huge in comparison to her normal sized
human parents her mom and dad brought
her to the island of elbaf
the home of giants they are also known
as the warriors of elbaf
not gonna lie her backstory is super
tragic so there's your warning as far as
we can tell
charlotte had a good natured heart and
good intentions
and you can't really blame a
five-year-old for what they do anyways
but her parents decided to abandon her
on the island they told her to wait for
them but they had no intention of coming
back
they encouraged her with sweets and
charlotte promised to be a good girl
and to wait and so she waited and waited
and waited her mother did feel bad about
abandoning her but the father told her
she caused so much damage
that exile was merciful and that she was
too much for them to handle
they put their hopes in the holy mother
of the land aka mother carmel to look
after her
time passed the weather changed it
snowed and still
giant little charlotte continued to wait
she got hungry
and cried out for her parents but they
never came lucky for her
mother carmel had founded an orphanage
named house of lambs that took in
children without anywhere else to go
regardless of their status and race and
charlotte was clearly such a child
an 80 year old carmel gave her a home
and
a place where she could potentially
belong and live with others in happiness
charlotte was super cheery about the
whole thing she smiled brightly not
complaining about the absence of her
parents but thankful that she found a
place where she could live
and eat elbaf was very cool for her too
since she was used to being huge
compared to everyone else but here she
saw people homes and sites
that were her own size for the first
time and she found it to be a very
comforting place
however problems began to pop up again
in one case charlotte saw
bear and wolf fighting in the woods she
knew that fighting was bad so she put
them in a cage together so they could
learn to be friends
then the bear ate the wolf so she
smacked the bear for being naughty but
even though charlotte was around 5 years
old her power was so great that the
little smack
instantly killed the bear charlotte
cried she didn't mean for things to turn
out like that
carmel seemed like a saint though and
cheered charlotte up
she focused on how charlotte was such a
sweet kind girl for wanting them to be
friends
and charlotte felt so touched that
someone understood her for the first
time in her life
in another case she was trying to smack
a mosquito that was on a giant and
accidentally broke several of his bones
and it goes on carmel continued to
forgive though and tried to make
everyone else forgive her too
reminding them that charlotte meant well
ten months passed and the mighty
warriors of
elbaf were generous enough to welcome
linlin among them they introduced their
custom
of a 12-day fast to her where they only
drink water
for 12 days and then had a feast and as
you may have guessed
fasting for 12 days is not a good idea
for everyone especially not for linlin
seven days in charlotte blacked out and
went on a rampage
looking for the delicious dessert called
semla she straight up destroyed the
village of
elbaf a respected giant warrior chief
called jorul
decided that charlotte only looked like
a child but was actually a god of
disaster
he went to kill her and she broke his
sword with her bare hand
took him by his beard and slammed him
into the ground
ja rule aka chief beard hill another old
and respected giant warrior was about to
finish off charlotte
after she got semla and fell asleep but
carmel begged for mercy and promised to
take her and leave
and she got her wish joe rule died from
his wounds and when charlotte woke up
she had no idea what had happened she
even had tears in her eyes after hearing
use of the death
word spread of what happened and not
surprisingly
the giants did not like lindelin anymore
as it turned out carmel was actually in
the kid-selling business
all along and every other year she sold
the liveliest orphans to the government
she wanted to do so with linlin too who
could potentially become an admiral
or even fleet admiral one day she was
going to retire after this
her last big score so she continued to
play the part of holy mother
on her sixth birthday lindland got a big
birthday cake
she was so happy she cried tears of joy
she was surrounded by friends and her
precious mother carmel
there was laughter and merriment the
tears kept flowing to the point where
she couldn't see through them
she was so happy she ate and kept eating
and when it was all over
everyone was gone only scraps of clothes
remained
suggesting that on the happiest day of
her life linlin zoned out
and ate the only family she had and this
traumatized linlin who continued to look
for her mother
and her friends but never found them and
to this day she is traumatized by how
mother carmel the only person who seemed
to understand her
vanished just like her parents did this
childhood trauma would seemingly become
her biggest weakness by the way a giant
witnessed what lindland did
to the others and reported it back to
elbaf cementing the hate the giants had
for linlin even further linlin
also inherited carmel's soul-soul fruit
during the incident
a failed pirate cook named strewson also
saw what happened he had to cook cook
fruit which allowed him to turn anything
into food
he introduced himself to lindlen's
seeing potential and we're told that
this meeting launched the eventual big
mom pirates
talking to this cook a six-year-old
linlin revealed that her dream was to
make a land of peace
a land that mother carmel would like
linland's bounty started out at 50
million berries and then went up to 500
million
she used her powers to get sweets
offering a land of peace and dreams
if people complied if they disobeyed
though they'd be killed because they
were being selfish and didn't want
everyone to be happy
lindland eventually turned the island
she was on into whole cake island
with the help of the soul soul fruit she
inherited from carmel
she also dreamed of making everyone
gigantic so they could sit at the table
together as
equals clearly her methods and rationale
are
deeply flawed but from her backstory
it's clear that lindlin didn't want to
be a monster
she was well intentioned but
circumstances helped turn her into the
kind of pirate
she eventually became at 18 lindelin
gave birth to her first child
pero sparrow she then proceeded to give
birth about once a year thereafter for
42 years
which helped her earn the title of big
mom she would eventually have 85
children
with 43 husbands and this is possible
because she sometimes gave birth to
multiple children at once
as in the case with twins and even the
couplets
if that's how it's pronounced which is
when 10 babies are born at the same time
as mentioned she did join the rox
pirates for a time
but after the god valley incident the
crew lost his captain and disbanded
33 years ago like fellow x rocks pirates
kaido and whitebeard she was working on
building her own crew
the big mom pirates and we already
mentioned during kaido's backstory that
somewhere along the way
big mom did a big favor for kaido and so
kaido still owes her for that
like kaido big mom got her hands on one
of the four poneglyphs
needed to get to laughdale and according
to her she screwed
up and let roger read the stone which is
how he was able to beat her to laptail
and become the pirate king however she
plans to be the next one to reach it
and she plans to use daughter number 35
the currently 16 year old pudding
whose father was from the 3i tribe to do
it if three eye tribe people
achieved true awakening as it's called
then they are supposed to be able to
read ponoglyphs
so that's linland's hope now let's turn
to daughter lola for a second
the twin sister of chiffon and daughter
of pound
one day she had a surprise suitor who
claimed he fell in love at first sight
it was prince loki of elbaf
for big mom it was a perfect opportunity
because she could finally fix the
strained relationship with the giants
with this marriage
and in the process gain what's held to
be the mightiest fighting force in the
world
the elbaf warriors but lola ran away
wanting to marry for true love and they
tried to pass off chiffon
as lola as a result but it didn't work
and things got even worse with the
giants
as chiffon tells us after that big mom
finally gave up on having real giants in
their group and began investing in
gigantification research and said
so she could turn humans into giants big
mom was furious and she took it out on
chiffon
because she looked like lola in a
parallel with kaido
she clobbered lola her own daughter and
knowing her backstory now
it's clear that big mom's murderous
hatred was probably tied to her trauma
of being abandoned by her family as a
child that's the thing big mom seems to
fear the most
and she could never forgive lola because
she did just that
she left her five years ago the knox
pirates aka the knox expedition party
a pirate crew of minks led by pedro were
looking for a poneglyph
the search brought the crew to big mom's
territory and they suffered a
devastating defeat
pedro's partner spun big mom's roulette
wheel
and his punishment was a hundred years
being sucked out of him he had only 30
left
and he died she was going to take the
remaining 70 out of pedro
but peckhams pleaded for mercy saying
pedro was like a brother to him
so she knocked 10 years off leaving 60.
baron tamago
lost his eye in a fight with pedro so
big mom didn't want to show
any more mercy however pedro was
determined to return home
and so he sacrificed his own eye asking
how much years would that buy
an eye for an eye and all that big mom
pretty impressed with pedro
finally settled on taking 50 years from
him and so
pedro survived lastly i'll mention that
big mom did have a deal with vinsmoke
judge
to marry her daughter pudding with
judge's son sanji for the sake of a
political alliance
however she actually planned to
assassinate the vinsmoke family
the whole time and to take their army of
clone soldiers
and their scientific power however her
plan continued to be delayed
because as we know they couldn't locate
sanji
and that is every yonko's backstory and
i know a lot of you would like to see
luffy's backstory too
since some do consider him to be an
emperor already
as well but we'll leave him for every
straw hats backstory explained a video
will get started on as soon as we get 6
000 likes on this video so i'll make you
guys work a bit for it
and that is it for this very very long
video
my throat actually hurts from how long
i've been talking
i've also been working on the script on
and off for a while so if you did enjoy
it please smash that like button and
when we hit 6
000 likes i'll get started on the straw
hat back stories next
you can also help the cause by sharing
this video with any cultured pirates
that you know
and asking them to smash that like
button if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all where you will miss future one piece
videos
let me know who your favorite yonko is
let me know which yonko's backstory
is your favorite so far and while you
wait for the next one piece video to
drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist which contains videos
about the powers of the yonko
the warlords supernovas and much much
more link
in the description thanks again to this
plate for sponsoring this video make
sure to check them out
link in the description and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you